[Music]
sleepwalk with me let me make this point
this is your first time directing yes
this is really your baby you do your
directing here was it a difficult this
process it was so hard it was the
hardest thing that I have ever done and
it's a very hard thing to convince
people when you've never directed a
feature film that you should be the
director of the film it's a little bit
like showing up in middle school for the
field trip and instead of sitting down
on one of the seats on the bus you go
hey everybody today I'm gonna drive the
bus everyone's like what like you don't
know how to drive the bus and you're
like I know but I've been watching the
bus driver I've been watching other bus
rides I have my favorites and my less
favorites and I feel like I have a bus
driving aesthetic that's gonna carry us
through and then some people are just
like I'm getting off the bus so you know
and I don't blame them but then some
people stay on the bus and eventually we
arrived at the end of this metaphor
[Laughter]
safely we say
you sleepwalk with me let me just
quickly explain that title you have a
sleep disorder this is a real sleep
disorder that you suffer from where you
physically act out your dreams
yeah it's called REM behavior disorder
and it's a rare sleepwalking disorder
and it's a convenient metaphor for a
film and also and yeah and I and I
actually we've talked about this on the
show before cuz I talked about the right
book but I said when I go to bed at
night I sleep in a sleeping bag up to my
neck and I wear mittens so I can't open
the sleeping bag you you once maybe Alex
but you're like struggling to get it so
I go you made the point once that I'm
like a worm yeah you're just trying to
get out and and it's so this is a real
disorder that you have a real discerning
you know what it's aggravating by is
making films about it deprived and I'm
directing myself acting as myself acting
out experiences and I would I would I
would have I had a slew of fuses kind of
sleepwalking incidents where my wife
would come in and she bill and I would I
would be adjusting lamps like I would
literally be like you know in in my
bedroom I would be sleep directing and
my wife would say what are you doing and
I'd say we're shooting and she'd say no
we're not shooting and I'd say I'm sorry
but we are patronize her which is the
most insulting thing you can do when
you're sleepwalking is be like oh you're
so stupid yeah
get a load of this one over here who
thinks I'm asleep yeah but you got a
movie out of it that's the other thing
and we have a clip here from sleepwalk
with me anything we need to know for
this is should we just go my master in
the film my character matt pandamiglio
is a struggling comedian I even changed
that's I played Conan Orion what's the
boy Conan doe yeah all right let's take
away this clip okay I could be honest
with ya she wants me to do half hour I
only have like ten minutes of material
oh really Wow you're gonna have to fill
out that time somehow man do some crowd
work talk to the audience make fun of
people whenever I make fun of people
they punch me nice shirt loser sorry no
I like it
to see Mary Marc Maron movie playing
Sigmund Freud famous Lexington playing
mark mujeres